okay okay welcome everyone to the ddps
seminar before we introduce our invited
speaker let's go over some rules and
Logistics first of all please mute
yourself during the talk unless you have
questions
if you have questions you are welcome to
unmute and ask otherwise please use chat
room to post your questions so that we
can address them in Q a session at the
end second today is gdps seminar is open
to external audiences and therefore no
classified discussion is allowed so
please watch out
finally The Talk today will be recorded
and uploaded in our YouTube channel
that's about it now let me introduce our
speaker today
it is an honor to host Ajay Harish who
is an assistant professor of engineering
simulation and data science in the
department of mechanical Aerospace and
civil engineering at the University of
Manchester prior to arrival in at
Manchester as I was awarded a bachelor's
in mechanical engineering from
nitk suratco in India a master's degree
in Aeronautics from Caltech in U.S and a
doctorate in the mechanical engineering
from
libnes University Hanover in Germany and
he was back in California for the
postdoc at the
nheri Sim Center at UC Berkeley his
research group at Manchester develops
numerical methods for uncertainty
quantification or application in
modeling waterborne hazardous problems
like a storm surge and tsunamis
today Ajay will talk more about the
uncertain uncertainty quantification and
deep learning for water hazard
prediction
which will be very interesting topic so
please enjoy and expect a wonderful talk
now without further Ado let me pass the
button to Ajay by asking one random
question as usual today's random
question it's not a random question
um
the same questions we've been asking
what is your favorite thing to do other
than research
especially in the weekends what do you
do in weekend
yeah I currently I'm spending weekends
making grants but uh I think
I wouldn't say that the most favorite
thing to do I played a violin so that
kind of let's say I have something that
I would enjoy doing oh that's lovely if
I get a little more time I would say so
yeah that's lovely that's lovely okay
stage is yours
thank you also thank you so much for the
introduction and for the invite for the
gdps seminar uh today I'll be as I used
to said I'll be talking about uh some
ideas about uncertainty quantification
particularly related to water hazards
and waterborne hazards like tsunamis and
Storm surges and anybody in California
is probably not new to these events like
so especially tsunami is somebody on
East Coast definitely has heard of storm
surge uh especially there's a recent Ida
hurricane there which uh created quite a
bit of Devastation in a way uh so
I'll try to focus a little bit on the
physics of the problem as well just to
highlight because uh not everybody might
be aware of how how these events are
modeled and how are we looking at it and
what are the different scales and things
like that but before I go ahead I would
just like to just to give a brief
General introduction about some of the
work that's done in my labs since the
overview of today's talk uh so what is
the story of what we are doing in our
lab here in Manchester uh then about
ladies inside a lot of work that I'm
talking today uh was done at UC Berkeley
and I'm continuing on that and this is
one of the directions we recently
submitted a grant to look at debris
loading on structures and so on and so
what are these waterborne hazards and
why are they important probably uh I
would I don't have to stress on the why
what are the modeling techniques and
answers and how do we do uncertainty
quantification in there so it's a very
high dimensional problem which makes it
really difficult to do anything in here
like so and as we go ahead you will see
what what's what are the difficulties
involved and I would definitely welcome
more ideas and I'm open to for
discussions in a way right so just to
give an idea of what we do in our lab uh
there are two things one is the
application side of things looking at
different applications like storm surge
tsunamis waterborne hazards fluid
structure interaction problem at the
moment I'm also looking at biomedical
problems related to neurovascular blood
flows and on the other side we develop
methods that can be used in there a lot
of matters already there and how do you
improve these methods how do we make
them better how do we especially look at
code coupling in a way how do we couple
different methods to look at their
advantages for example we are trying to
couple at the moment material Point
method with finite volume method
material Point that's very good with
regard to large deformations in
structures but then it has lot of
integration issues when you're looking
at flow problems where finite volume
does very well can we couple these
methods to uh let's say do more robustly
and of course a big part of it is
uncertainty quantification and machine
learning as well to accelerate some of
these simulations with surrogate models
and so on so once our application the
one thing that we are looking at is a
tribological applications there are a
lot of emission standards out there for
exhaust remissions or when they say
exhaust emission anything coming out of
a tail pipe and especially with the with
the push for electric vehicles I think
this is something that's going to go
down
but what has not been classified or like
kind of characterized well is
non-exhaust emissions so this is
something related to tire wear and brake
wear I mean it doesn't appear like a
very very very let's say appealing
problem to look at him who cares about
the tires in a way right I mean that
kind of like somewhat the attitude is
there with a lot of Industry as well as
long as the tires last for a while we
don't care but then a big problem is all
the two on PM 2.5 particles and pm10
particles that's a significant
contributor to it but then there are no
emission standards that really regulate
these kind of political sizes coming out
of it so that's kind of something where
we are looking at also we do some bit of
traditional mechanics related to contact
Mechanics for example a simple this is
just example of uh what is called as a
flying spaghetti problem so if you have
spaghetti and just drop it down how is
it going to like you know uh you know
fold around and it's actually in a 2d
problem in a way or looking at contacts
mechanics between very flexible bodies
and slender structures or 31 3D contact
which kind of has applications in
tribology and so on I mean tribology if
you look at it there's a lot of
Uncertain parameters in there right from
the road surface to the material model
so it's extremely high dimensional
uncertainty quantification problem that
to look at
and one of the recent uh applications of
us have been to look at data driven
modeling in uh uh in looking at carotid
and stroke related issues uh how do we
quantify the risk of a patient for
example when a patient comes in they
either come in they have they look at it
they say okay probably the patient needs
a surgical intervention or they go back
and probably they come back again for
surgical intervention or it's pretty
much late so how do we kind of say that
okay this patient has a high risk for a
stroke and somebody does not have a high
risk for a stroke
so there we are combining fluid
mechanics simulation with deep learning
techniques and biasial neural networks
in order to quantify the stroke between
different patients and predict some form
of risk in a way a new thing that we
started out was to look at the cerebral
flows uh especially regarding the
neurogenerative disorders and to look at
the Occidental level you know one thing
is that we can easily image is the
larger capillaries but we cannot image
sorry larger arteries but we cannot
image the smaller capillaries at veins
and one of the difficulties that many of
the let's say very hard to do
automatically with a neural network is
to be able to decipher between what
salary what's the capillary and what's
the way in a way so can we automatically
do use neural networks to build these uh
vascular structure in our brain and look
at oxygen levels and eventually look at
how the how these lack of oxygen
degrades the brain tissue and so on so
this has been a uh newly Stars work that
new work that we started it's just like
this will start a working program but
just to give you an idea of it apart
from the natural hazards one of the
other areas that I'm looking at is
biomedical uh problems where there's a
lot of uncertainty quantification to
think about uh
in a way right so just to start with a
lot of this work that I'm talking today
was done with the Navy and Sim Center at
UC Berkeley so just to give an idea
about them because without talking about
them this would be very uh I'll just do
the contributions that come from Navy
and from the Sim Center into this work
that we have done so lady is a network
of natural hazards engineering research
infrastructure so it has several uh
experimental facilities for example like
there's a wall of wind in New York City
of Florida the
large wave Flume Facility in Oregon
State University and so on there's
earthquake in Lucy you see San Diego uh
these are I think at least the ones that
I had interactions with and there are
several other also uh experimental
facilities that contribute into
different natural hazards and Sim Center
is the
and it's a competition modeling and
Simulation Center where we were
developing or We are continuing we're
continuing to develop a lot of
computational infrastructure that goes
into these uh softwares to simulate
natural hazards and so on
so the goal of the Asian Center has been
to build a very modular open source
framework so you can go to the GitHub
all of this is available on GitHub all
the work that we do where we have built
it in a very modular fashion for example
I said how do you characterize assets
for example in the building
infrastructure how do you get the
information about that how to
characterize the hazard like tsunamis
and storms of this earthquake and uh
wind hazards and so on and how do you
eventually come out to the response of
it you know how do we build a more
resilient infrastructure in a way
of course a lot a lot of this started
with looking at earthquake
social Center is currently in the second
phase of the funding from NSF
in the first phase a lot of focus was on
the initial Focus was on the earthquake
engineering so that's where a lot of
uncertainty quantification also started
with and eventually this has been
adapted also for the water Hub on
hazards and the wild bone hazards and so
on in a way so what what we see here is
essentially I think we should be quite
some pointer here somewhere
oh
okay so what we are saying here is the
in the red box here is what we call the
coffin and co-fem essentially is the uh
couples the uncertainty quantification
with finite element and eventually all
of it just runs on a cloud with his
attack supercomputer in Texas uh and
hydro uq essentially uses the also uses
along with it brings in tsunamis and
storms of indentation and cfd as well
into the fork
so the whole idea is to combine
earthquake which is the euq VQ is a wind
Hydro uq is the water and give a
probabilistic assessment through PB and
r2d so where people can use that to
build more resilience based decision
making and so on uh but today we'll
focus on this one thing called hydro uq
and look at how these water bone hazards
are especially uh modeled and second
thing is what are the uncertainties that
come into this modeling these events and
how do we account for them in a way
right
okay
so first
I think several of most of you would be
familiar with tsunamis a big one that
happened was in 2004 uh
where there was severe damage to pores
and Coastline a lot of these damage
happened because of the debris for
example here on the bottom we can see
the Indonesia Coastline before and after
the tsunami on the left side as before
with a lot of recover and so on on the
right side is right after the tsunami
where everything has been washed out uh
a lot of these uh debris have like less
than 10 meters per second speed but then
they can be very very damaging when they
kind of crash into these into the
building infrastructure and so on so the
tsunami basically killed about uh 250
000 people
and so magnitude of 9.2 I add we
understand the largest wave was about 30
meters or like about 100 feet uh
when when the tsunami said and so that's
essentially kind of washing away
literally anything on the track so one
of the things that's very important in
these kind of events is to build
vertical evacuation structures that can
resist these kind of floors with a
horizontal evacuation in these uh
event is almost impossible to think
about so people try to do a horizontal
evacuation and that doesn't happen that
kind of that eventually leads to a loss
of life and the property but then if we
can build large evacuation structures
that are vertical in nature that could
probably save a lot of lives and I mean
same thing happens for example these are
like this uh 2010 Chile tsunami where
there's again a lot of damage to the
port where the shipping containers and
ships as you can see moved into the port
the ships have very very small velocity
at this point but eventually they have a
large mass so they're bringing large
amount of momentum that can really
destroy these uh infrastructures So
eventually we want to make sure that
these infrastructures can withstile the
loads that are there and they don't get
damaged in a way thank you
right so this one very uh interesting
even that uh not interesting but then
very uh important even that was missed
quite a bit during the 2011 tohoku
tsunami uh where there was supposedly
two submarines uh in inside this port
and these two submarines when the water
entered in through the port the
submarines were basically rotating
around there uh as the water left
through it so they did not there's not
much damage so they did not come up into
the news but there that could be a very
significant important thing to account
for on where these ships and submarines
can be parked and how to account for
this uh kind of Hazard events and so on
right so
and the similar things happens during a
storm surges for example there's a
building that happened in 2005 during
Katrina storm surge and so you can see
the uh the oil rig before and after the
significant amount of damage and so this
is a category 5 hurricane this was very
similar event happened with a hurricane
Ida recently on the Mississippi Where
the River started flowing backwards for
about two hours from the Atlantic Ocean
so instead of flowing into the Atlantic
it was flowing outside back into the
land for about two hours and then then
the floor was restored this was uh uh in
the storm said it's not just the water
waves but also wind that adds an
additional damage that can create a lot
of wind debris that can really damage
these infrastructure and so on so
there's so essentially we need to we
cannot let's stop these events from
happening but then we need to build our
infrastructure that has that are
resilient and that can account for these
kind of events and that automatically
saves that that we need to account for
different range of events you know it
can be a small event it can be a large
event but it can be once in a hundred
year even but then how do we account for
these things and that's where uq comes
into the picture as uh you would already
guessed in a way right
so just to give an idea for uh what what
what's the storm surge and how does it
happen uh one can think about it that
there's a center of low pressure around
which all the water is being drawn and
as this low pressure area moves towards
the land this water is kind of pushed
towards the land so people can expect
about 15 to 20 meters uh 20 feet of
storm tide very easily and again this
depends on the magnitude of the event
and the low pressure area and so on but
even during storms are one of the
biggest thing is also the wheel driven
Surge and also the wheel driven debris
and I mean that kind of coming along
with the storm surge uh as well so
there's two kinds of tsunamis as well
I'm going back and forth between storm
surge and tsunamis because uh though the
there are different kinds of events
eventually at the end of the day when it
comes to modeling very similar
approaches are taken for both of these
events and uh so guys we will see later
on uh if you look at what colors a
tsunami one is either like you have a
seismic event which is earthquake so the
motion of the fault so it is roughly
quick crudely to think about you have
something of ocean floor that suddenly
moved up which meets a whole block of
water has moved up and now you suddenly
this this block of water has to go
somewhere and it kind of moves towards
the land and second thing is Landslide
which we never think of the uh that to
be uh creating a large magnitude tsunami
but these are highly localized tsunami
and one of the largest tsunamis where
there's uh over 400 meter way was in
Alaska in 1958 so these are very
localized events but then this can
create a lot of damage in that
particular region uh where there's a
huge landslide that is happening right
uh just to just to look at some of the
modeling approaches uh
you so please tell please let me know
when I'm running out of time uh yeah I
will do that yeah yeah thank you so just
to look at some of the modeling
approaches because that kind of makes it
important to understand how do we put uq
into the problem what's the problem in
there before we can put uq into it right
so just
mechanics course and so I don't have to
talk about this a wavelength what's a
Crest what's that trough what's the wave
height and wavelengths all right so but
then just to get us all on the same page
right so we have to crust and distance
between them in the wavelength and
distance between the trough and the
crust is basically the wave height right
so one of the thing is essentially what
happens with uh this uh kind of events
like tsunamis they're very long
wavelength so in the ocean you in a deep
ocean you will never recognize that a
tsunami is coming in because the
wavelengths are very long compared to
their compared to the depth of the ocean
floor so but then only what what would
happen is actually these things was a
very crude image of what would happen as
the wave moves towards the shore the
depth of the ocean floor is starting to
reduce which means that this energy that
is coming in has to go somewhere and the
height of the wave eventually increases
and that's what's uh what leads to a lot
of Devastation in a way because as soon
as it starts to meet the ocean floor the
wave starts to slow down and once it
starts to slow down the faster moving
waves starts to crash it starts to break
in a way right so uh cruelly to think
about this kind of lead to a lot more
Devastation because a wave breaking
effects and so on that that it has a lot
of interest to the community
the amplitude of the wave is much larger
much smaller than the wavelength and the
depth of the ocean
the flow moves over a complex
documentary or topography sort of ocean
floor is pretty complex uh and one of
the things it evolves over multiple lens
scales right so in the ocean you know
open ocean where we have kilometer
resolution but then when they come to
the near the coast you need to look at a
meter resolution as we'll see some of
the results later on you will see that
we need adaptive mesh refinement in
order to account for different uh sets
of grids that are there both in the
ocean floor so deep ocean and in near
the coast in a way right
okay so this is the what we did we
developed this uh tool called Hydro uq
that combines the ideas of
uh that brings together let's say a 3D
finite element 3D uh computational fluid
dynamics which where we use open source
tool open form and we brought in Shallow
Water Solutions and we will see later on
how all of these things are combined so
but just to give you an idea so most of
our infrastructures Coastal
infrastructure which is at risk for
example it can be looked at as these
buildings that are highlighted in this
yellow colored boxes and so these are
our buildings of Interest either it
could be an offshore structure or it
could be a structure right on the course
and there could be either a fault or a
low pressure Zone that is driving the
water and that would be our domain of
interest for our 2D shallow water
solution so if you want to do a la if
you want to do cfd stimulation over a
large domain then you really need a huge
computation results I I don't even know
if it's possible and I've never tried it
personally but maybe people do it for
meteorology people from meteorology do
these kind of simulations but in the uh
most of the communications these waves
are more shallow water waves the shallow
Waters to the shallow water solver is
used in the deep ocean but I'll come
into the coastline you need a much more
higher Fidelity solution those these
shallow Waters can capture the
irundation heights reasonably well they
are not so good at capturing the forces
on these structures which is kind of
what we want to look at the building
response eventually right and so there
we combine this with open form or any
any kind of a 3D software and the
building itself is looked at with 3D
finite element and some uncertain
quantification looking at the building
response uh at this point of time we
were not interested in looking at what
is the uh uh let's say like uncertainty
in the event itself but more like what
would be uncertainty in a structural
response for a particular event ually So
eventually that the idea would be also
to become combined to like looking at
uncertainty between different sets of
events in a way and that kind of that
makes it harder because the uh looking
at 3D cfd with uncertainty
quantification makes it uh very time
consuming and that's kind of where 3D
FEA is really fast so essentially
coupling uncertainty quantification with
that is much more easier and more
computationally efficient than doing it
with 3D cfd full Fidelity CFT in a way
right so just to give an idea of depth
average also we have like basically that
now is total equation which is our
momentum conservation and mass
conservation and what we start by doing
is looking at let's say if we start to
neglect why they are components and
let's say Y is our depth we start to
neglect that and we start to look at it
as a 2d problem uh let's say on the
clock no we just start to look at it as
a 1D problem that says that is our depth
and U is X is our One Direction in which
the wave is propagating then we can
reduce our navier strokes and our Mass
conservation to uh to one less equation
in there and now what we want to do is
we want to couple everything with uh
with our boundary conditions so we have
a free surface which we call Theta and
bottom surface as B and we can say that
we can kind of couple our velocities we
can say that our velocity is at the
bottom surface is maybe uh is is zero
and the pressure at the top surface is
zero essentially so we use our boundary
conditions and we we can really we can
always generalize this into 2D we
started the uh we and what we need to do
is we need to integrate all the depth
right so uh and I'll just show you the
one day one day in a way but we can
always add the Y component to it which
will give you an additional equation if
they are dou U by dou X is nothing but
the in X Direction and Y direction would
be on the other side of the surface or
the direction of the surface
perpendicular to that and that is our
depth that we under looking at primarily
what we want to do is we want to
integrate over the depth right so we are
integrating B is our bottom surface or
the ocean floor to either which is
nothing but our uh let's say a free
surface so once we are able to integrate
over from bottom surface to the top
surface take our navier stoves all of
this reduces into a much simpler form
which is looking at how is the variation
of the height with regard to time and
what is the variation of uh do they say
height is essentially or bathymetry they
say the height of the water column at
that particular time at a particular
point and U Bar is nothing but the depth
average velocity at that particular
point at that particular time so both
are function of uh X comma Y and time
and H is nothing but the water column
which is kind of changing as you would
expect
right so just all of these leads to a
very nice uh assumptions that uh that
leaves us with a 2d equation to solve on
the shallow Waterfront in a way so again
we can always uh increase that and we
can write it in a very nice form for our
steady state where we can say our steady
state ocean is represented by the H is
the water column height and the B is the
location of our bathymetry so we Define
a mean surface and with regard to that
we can say that is equal to zero so zero
is our mean surface when the ocean floor
is at illustrady state so that kind that
accounts for let's say any kind of
variation that are that is there for the
water
right
so I'll skip a couple of uh equations uh
here but uh
everybody can come back to that as we as
we progress through the seminar we can
come back and have a look at these
equations in a way so what what happens
during the tsunami initiation is that we
are just saying that our free surface
Has Changed by some amount so we say
that e t hours which is our free surface
is no longer at zero which is no longer
at a steady state but the height of the
ETA which is a free surface has changed
for some amount and automatically this
uh D ETA by DT progresses over the
entire set of equations in a way right
okay
so all of these gives you a very nice
set of hyperbolic equations and shallow
water that we need to solve one of the
things that has to be done is we need to
discretize when we take a 2d domain and
we need to discretize it we have to
divide them as like a wet cell and a dry
cells so that is what makes it a little
more complicated a vessel is where
there's some water or the height of the
water column is non-zero and the dry
cell is uh where the height of the water
column is zero so because we are taking
the bathymetry of the ocean floor but we
also are taking the Topography of the
land overall and now as the water
progresses it can move from one cell to
the other in a discretized state where
the where our mesh can change from a wet
state to a dry State and right state to
wet state so there can be a state which
are always sweat which are always dry
this is the land and the word ocean but
then the coastal region would always
change between the wet State and Detroit
State and that that needs to be
accounted for when we are looking at the
ocean from so just to give you some
examples of the so here here this
hypothetical magnitude 7 earthquake so I
wouldn't say that the last question that
happened or there's a something that
would happen but there's a hypothetical
case so I just want to be careful on
that uh on Alaska fault uh so where we
are looking at two points of interest
one is the Crescent City in California
and the second one is Honolulu in Hawaii
and there's adaptive image refinement
that has been used from level one to
level six so this is what I was saying
that when we are looking at a particular
region let's say on the ocean then we
are looking at a level one grid which is
very unrefined and on a when we are
looking at some kind of a coastal region
then you need to refine this area so
that you can get a much cleaner and
better resolution
let's say results on the coast where we
are trying to look at these events so
this grid size just to give you an idea
one degree is about uh 110 kilometers
that is about the grid size on the ocean
in the deep ocean that we are looking at
and about uh and when we are looking at
near the uh coastal region we are
looking about about half a second where
the grid resolution is about 15 meters
so that's just to give you an idea of
the uh different grids that are being
used and this original case was run in
collaboration with Professor Patrick
Leonard at USC so this was done when we
are well now there DC Berkeley and there
are two regions of Interest one is the
place in Honolulu and one is the coastal
region in Crescent City in California
and so there's just a visualization as
the wave progresses what we are looking
at the red and blue is essentially the
rough and crest of the tsunami wave that
is propagating in a way so this has been
as we see later even though the scale is
between 0.2 to minus 0.2 to plus 0.2
meters that's because that's the let's
say the uh
wave amplitude that reaches Honolulu in
Hawaii but then in Crescent City that's
more than six meters as we will see you
know in a couple of minutes from now
so as you see uh I don't know if you
observed but probably it's something
that we can go back and again look at it
is if you look at this this is a 110
kilometer grid as you see there so the
grid is extremely uh there are further
more cells in there but then there is
just the outline so that it doesn't look
very bad uh the grid is extremely
and it says sparse in a way it's not
dense but as we
as the simulation progresses there's
adaptive wish refinement that has that
is there in geoclaw so most of these
simulations were done in geopla you can
see here the Crescent City and again
near Honolulu in Hawaii the smaller bits
are there so this is not exactly a level
six grade that you have same to the
level sixth grade would be much more
dense in there so these are like the
much more smaller grids that are used
near the coastal region in order to get
a much more refined solution and much
higher accuracy with regard to
inundation depth and so on you know
so again just just to look at the level
one uh grid for the entire base and this
is what we were looking at but that's
something that was imposed on on Google
Maps uh again we can see that the
different levels of grids come into
picture and then when the wave
propagates in there so these cells are
essentially like a wet or dry that I was
showing in there earlier as I went all
dry kind of changes these additional
grids that are there are adapted by Geo
Cloud automatically
so this is a level six Grid in the
Crescent City in uh in there at the
okay
can you see okay yeah so initially when
you start this level sixth grade is just
one big cell it's not been there but now
as the water flows in you can see that
it really adapts in there to give a much
better resolution so now all this is
much higher level Grid that you can see
all the different coastal structures
that uh that are there so as the water
your progress is in these additional
grids are take over in order to give a
much better refined solution for the
problem with that
yeah so this is again like a Crescent
City where we can
see the there's basically a
cross-sectional area of the Crescent
City that is there where we are looking
at the water progression and we can see
that the there's one wave coming in so
there's a second wave that goes up to
six meters and the third wave that's
about a little more than two meters now
if you go back to see that so we can see
the looking at the water level series we
saw that there was a a small wave coming
in and then there's a wave that went up
to about six meters and there was a
third wave it came in so it's not just
one single wave that comes in during the
event but then there were multiple views
that could come in at different uh
levels again if we go back again to
Honolulu to look at that we can see the
same kind of a event in a way but then
here we have as you saw the wave
amplitude was much smaller and that was
the reason why in the original video the
wave amplitude was kept at 0.2 meters so
you can see everything is really red but
uh there is so much of an event here
so just again like if you look at the
water level this is between about minus
two two plus two point minus point two
two plus point two meters in a way uh in
Honolulu while about six meters in
Crescent City California right so so
these are the kind of modeling
techniques that are used uh during these
uh simulation so we are looking at
primary like shallow water simulations
in order to be able to get these
inundation depths so first thing is we
get the indentation depth but uh second
thing is what do you do next with this
unit direction right so we need to take
these inundation depth and somehow feed
it into a cfd software so what happens
here we have a 2d grid which is
essentially a nice Square grid on our uh
between a certain latitude and longitude
but now in a 3D simulation you have
essentially like a face that goes
through the entire ocean bottoms ocean
bathymetry in order to record for it so
there needs to be somehow conversion
which in some solid mechanic sense it's
basically like somebody's coming from a
solid mechanics background one can think
of connecting a beam or a plate to a
shell or a B one or plate to like a
solid in a way so you have a 3D object
to which you have a 1D or a 2d object
that's connected so this is essentially
the same kind of uh physics that needs
to be accounted for when we are
interpolating between a shallow water
solver into a cfd so anyway we have a
depth average velocity information that
needs to be converted into a full 3d
velocity of to input our cfd tool in a
way so guys Hydro uq does these things
it takes the input from the 2D water
shallow water solution that we were
discussing and inputs into as a boundary
condition into 3D open form in order to
run 3D Cod simulations so
once these three dcfd simulations have
run so that gives us some forces and
forces on our structures and that's
where we want to we had at that point of
time we had a focus to look at the
uncertainty quantification in these
structures
so a lot of work also I have to I have
to credit to sangri and Akash who also
did a lot of work on the uq methods that
have been developed uh and then they're
still currently at the same centers who
have been working on the uq methods as
well right so where so what what did you
want to look at so first thing is we
wanted to look at uh what is the
propagation of these uncertainties from
inputs to outputs right a simple thing
to think about is uh let's say we had
some kind of original design but then
there needs to be an alternative design
because of the uh different uh
displacement that these designs would
lead to in a way right so which design
should we select so that's where
uncertainty quantification comes in and
what are these building structures what
are the responses from these built-in
structures looking at these kind of
fluid loads that are coming in and
particularly looking at some of these
debris loads that are coming in as well
right
foreign
cost and what is the downtime and that's
uh one thing that has been seen is uh
these flood events significantly affect
more marginalized communities in a way
and how do we make the impact a little
lesser in a way so we want to understand
the overall uh uncertainties in our
inputs and how do their quantity how do
they let's say uh propagate through the
system in a way as the outputs are kind
of looking at what would be the repair
cost of downtime uh overall in a way
right so we want to do all of these
things and the simplest thing to start
out with is to say okay what would be
the ends modulus of the structure to
start with let's assume that this
structure is made of a steel structure
what would be the Ang's modulus of the
structure and if there's a variation in
links modulus you run a finite element
simulation get the response of it and so
to do some kind of forward sampling auto
reliability analysis to look at what
would be the significant damage in there
or even Global sensitivity analysis to
look at the importance of different
parameters that are there in these
structures and so on right so so these
are the kind of things that we wanted to
eventually do and let's say eventually
be able to make some kind of engineering
judgment in there so most of the times
let's say it's a structural engineers
don't want to run let's say cfd
simulation that would take 15 days or a
week or so and but then if I talk to
Engineers from this fluid mechanics side
they're very happy to have a week is a
normal CMD simulation for many of them
right but then for a structural engineer
designing a structure who wants they
would want quicker responses so kind of
they want more uh faster problems faster
Solutions in the kind of that kind of uh
makes it much harder to kind of bridge
both The Works in a way but then we want
to somehow bring in these things and we
want to understand this thing and a very
straightforward approach for us would
have been to do forward propagation
anyway so we built in the forward
propagation model where somebody puts in
a different things modulus and runs the
same takes the same fluid load but is
able to run the cfd rather cfd solution
has a set of forces over time A Time
series of forces and is able to run the
structural simulation in order to get
some form of a response but then again a
simple thing would be to run simple
Monte Carlo but then we are all we also
made it allowed things to for them to
run Latin hypercube method or even
surrogate model multiplicity modeling in
there as a to make it more numerically
less expensive
and so
again second thing that we wanted to do
was to look at reliability analysis too
so one of the things that is of interest
to a lot of uh natural hazards Engineers
to look at reliability errors and what
would happen if uh when would a model
let's say cross a particular threshold
in a way so I don't care about you know
what what would be the lows on the
structure what only I care about if it
is going to cross a particular threshold
if it crosses you will that's when my
structure will probably be at a risk to
damage or to break or to fail and most
of the most of the engineers Structural
Engineers want to understand that I want
to reduce the number of simulations in a
way for example let's say a 10 percent
would essentially mean a thousand
simulation the point zero zero one
percent would mean about 10 power 6
simulation in order to get that kind
that percentage of uh let's say accuracy
in a way and that that that's where we
are looking at uh important sampling and
subset simulations and some even
surrogate modeling and the combination
of both these kind of methods have been
incorporated into Hydro uq that would
allow the user in order to run their
simulations put a structural model in
there and be able to do the reliability
analysis and make a decision process so
to look at if it cross a particular
threshold the last couple of things that
are there in hydraulic used one is to
look at Global sensitivity analysis for
example if there's a users let's say or
all of these parameters equally
impacting the response for example there
could be the X models of the beam there
could be forces acting on the structure
and there can be variability in the
structural geometry itself in a way and
how do each of these different variables
impact and which is which has a high
sensitivity and which are the low
sensitivity to look at so-ball indexes
and so on so it Hydro uq makes it very
easy for a user in order to put these
things in there and run they run their
structural simulations run the cfd
shallow water and the structural
stimulation to do a global sensitivity
analysis they're very very
straightforward manner in a way and the
last thing that is there is looking at
surrogate models again like here we have
neural neural networks and gaussian
process that that has been incorporated
into hydro uq and uh
something that we are working on is to
look at looking at design of experiment
to make it more easily accessible to the
user that they can run these simulations
and do some form of design of
experiments including the cfd as well uh
so that kind of is our bottling like in
a way to see how we can do faster cfd
simulation shallow water runs very fast
but then the cfd is the bottleneck to
get High Fidelity in uh forces and a
Time series of forces in a very high
fidelity manner
so since uh people have been able to
easily build surrogate models and we are
able to use that particularly on the
structural side either one parameter
system two parameter system or even a
neural network gaussian process and so
on so one of the last thing that we
recently have is looking at inverse uq
or by Asian calibration where looking at
the stimulation and looking at the force
time series forces from the buildings go
back and let's update the distribution
after the observing the data in a way so
we'll start with the X modulus but based
on your simulation data be able to
update things models distribution so
that you're able to calibrate for the
kind of structure kind of forces and
that are that are there on the
structures and observed based on
observations and based on whatever your
simulation model is giving because
there's a lot of uncertainty in there
which we don't know about the structural
response itself in a way
uh
so sorry like this this has been used to
calibrate material models reduced order
model post given damage diagnosis uh
especially because there's a lot of
image that is available
post event to post disaster that can be
used and can this be used to create uh
you can we do by Asian calibration in
order to get the structural response and
how the structure would behave indicates
such an event hit the structures in a
way so just to I hopefully I'm still on
time and now there's some time for
questions uh so all of these things is
available on the aeration Center Hydro
uq so I would put the link to the master
one where you have to move to a latest
working version I would say so there are
other beta version that we are working
on but uh so you can on the Navy Sim
Center on the link you can find Hydro uq
software that should allow you to do all
of these uncertainty quantification
method not just you use uq but also be
able to couple that with shallow water
and cfd and finite element together so
that would leave it or leave this link
with you and I would be happy to answer
any questions wonderful thank you so
much for the wonderful talk Ajay
so let's have a q a sessions
[Music]
so I don't see any questions in the chat
yeah but while you guys are thinking
about those questions I I can ask some
of the questions you said you used a
neural net model
for the reduce reduce
what sort of the neural net model can
you elaborate
a bit more on that yeah yeah so so
the Hydro uq has both convolution neural
networks and rnns in a way because
there's a lot of Time series forecasting
so RNs and lstms are there available uh
but also all of this is kind of Open
Source so if a user wants to bring in a
different neural network architecture
they can add and then they can always
push in so the idea is to make it more
more Community contribution in there so
one of the recent things that is still
not available on the hydro uq is the
graph neural networks that we use so
where we were trying to build a
surrogate model not just for the
structural part of it but also for the
shallow water and see empty part of it
were used as a graph neural network in
order to let's say run some of these cfd
simulations and be able to train that
and that's where we were also working
with Latin hypercube method in order to
say okay what should be our next tfd
simulation that we do that would offer
us that would offspan most of our space
that we would want to in a way so we
combine that in hypercube method to
choose in the next set Cod simulations
and all of these was trained with the
graph neural network to create a servlet
model so there are two outcomes coming
out of this one was basically a
compression in a way so where uh so one
thing I mean this on the side let's say
side effect of it I would say so all of
these simulations were like if you think
of it each simulation is like a Blu-ray
disc and you put everything into a pen
drive right so that's that's essentially
the idea that we wanted to put in
caliber graph neural network we trained
on lot of these cfd simulations in order
to be able to replicate I mean
essentially that's a surrogate model and
that was something that we were able to
do very successfully in a way both for
cfdi for the shallow water solutions
and uh second thing that we were able to
do was uh it is not just you not just
Trail it as a surrogate but then now can
you uh for example one of the biggest
things for a lot of users on high HPC
systems
uh when you are working with hundreds of
processors is to download this data I
mean a very very crude mesh here gave
about 300 gigabytes of data that's a
very crude mesh a bad simulation I would
say so we were talking about terabytes
of data in a simulation and uh and
nobody wants to really download that to
do the post processing and things like
that
especially if you want to create
visualization so what we did was to
train the graph neural network with our
simulations and then you could download
your graph neural network instead of the
network and just download that
and you could train it at different
accuracy for example let's say if I'm
visualizing I don't need to have 100
accuracy I don't need six decimal data
second decimal digit is sufficient for
my visualization
so we were able to almost get a thousand
times compression because of that
anyway so you say okay I need a 90
accuracy which doesn't give me a sixth
uh decimal digital just a second decimal
digit and that pretty much gave you
almost a thousand times uh let's say
compression in a way and if you just
download that and use it for
visualization purposes
so this is this is not it put into Hydro
uq but this is the next thing that
should hopefully go in in the next
couple of months just curious I mean the
graph neural networking the training of
the graphene neural network can be very
demanding and you said that data is used
uh probably training itself it will be
pretty like the computationally
demanding
um yeah so yeah but you put all the
efforts
um you know ahead and then you know make
it available to the public
so the idea was what we did was to
create uh like a sub process so as the
cfd simulation is running every once it
finishes every step it there's also some
process that is running a parallel
process that is running with it which is
running the graph neural networks and
that uh sends a message to the graph
neural networks and saying that there's
a new result available and use that to
kind of do the batch training with it so
each each measure itself is quite big so
each a Time step is broken into much
smaller batches to do the training in a
way and there's also a bit of domain
decomposition in there to not just train
it as one single domain but as multiple
domains so that way you can before
received simulation runs complete
and you don't have to train every single
time step sometimes uh so we kind of try
to adaptively see if it can extrapolate
and check for the error with the
solutions and based on the error it
doesn't have to train that particular
time step but can skip the time step and
go ahead so that way you can save some
time as well in a way nice so basically
you you guys do this some Authority jobs
uh for us and then the users can gonna
take the data from the graph neural
network in compress right yeah yeah
exactly exactly so yeah so basically the
idea is essentially to make it make HPC
systems easily usable from the user so
they don't have to download all the data
because because this tool runs on the
Texas Advanced uh Computing Center and
let's say somebody who's never used the
HPC system can still use it because
there's a nice interface to use this so
they just give some bit button and
everything job submits there through and
I got away uh API but then like when the
once they said download and now this uh
it starts to download everything that
that could become a pain for the user to
use it right so then they don't want to
really use that so I tried to download
minimum amount of data because
everything what happens is all the
simulation data is now transferred to
design safe
uh they can go to this design safe
portal and from there access their
account and get all the data that run
from the stimulation so
it's a it's it's a bit uh old way of
doing things I would say but uh without
criticizing that so uh this uh the whole
design safe works is basically transfers
one file at a time from the tax system I
don't know because I didn't build it but
somebody else and built it so which kind
of really slows down when you have a lot
of files in a way so you want to
download everything as one single punch
in a way and that kind of downloading a
single neural network and just
repackaging it makes it much more easier
okay sounds good okay so during during
the you mentioned the latinum procure
for the sampling two file yeah to sample
Max time lights in hypercube is the
predefined
the design of the choice method so but
there are there is a physics basis based
sampling
um which can tell you where the maximum
errors in terms of the physics and then
you can use
information to determine where the next
sample would be so that that might give
you problems better better way of
sampling than simply using the printed
on the latinite per Cube okay so any
other that's a good feedback yeah
any other questions
Sergey has his hands raised I think oh
yeah okay yeah please unmute yourself
and then um
Sergey
you're welcome to mute yourself
thank you for very interesting
presentation
I have kind of
strange situation but like information
Give A reduced to be very important
uh what what you're doing to designated
to give this to city planners
lawyers which are like
making decisions like financing stuff
like buildings this vertical uh
expertise I don't know how to say
uh the whole specifications about
the predictions of earthquake
it can be a stimulant method to be used
paper but it's what I find striking it
was a nice flight about
uh
conditions from Cars
and if I get here right correctly
pollution
exhaust Decay to know the factors than
the other
and she was kind of striking for me so
just I'm asking Rosie you're doing to
popularize your data
and and I also see that like using
uh this kind of simulation or analysis
uh
making people to think again what
factors are involved
and in many cases before there was no
clear models to take the structure to
take out
and now you can do it even like without
a good physical model
and as this is a
quite important to realize all existing
models and factors and find meeting
factors so what you are doing about like
the popular right next idea of the
history for this one
question
no I I I I you broke up a little bit in
the middle uh you also were able to
catch all the questions like uh
you have a lot of interesting data
important data for people that are
lawyers and or city planners Etc
what they are doing to popular to make
them known to public to Vice public
wait okay yeah so yeah so I think civil
Center has its own uh way of publicizing
things uh I mean now I'm not officially
with the SIM Center so one thing that
I'm doing also in the UK at the moment
is uh trying to work with some of the
city the council here in Manchester in
the UK and also there's a Consortium
called CCP WSI plus so it's called the
computational center for wave structure
interaction so where they are also
looking at the tsunamis and storm
surgeons and these events and we are
trying to work with uh let's say so one
of the industries that we are looking at
is to look at if this would be
interesting to uh some insurance
Industries especially those who are
doing like reinsurance and looking at
Insurance in Hazard areas uh
particularly that could help them really
make a better assessment of what what
are the events that would happen in here
what is the real risk that is there that
could really reduce some of the premiums
that are being charged in a way so we
are trying to work with some of the
insurance companies and also with City
councils and city planners so uh to see
how we can
bring these tools into their design
process and to do their decision making
process uh but the difficulty is that uh
it's a it's a it's quite hard because uh
eventually uh
there's a lot of there's a lot of
uncertainties in the system so that kind
of makes it really hard for them to
let's say take a decision based on these
tools but there's
a very concerted effort trying to get it
to them in a way and trying to get them
to do it so one of the recent things
that I myself started was to look at the
debris for example UK recently released
the report that said that we don't
really have any kind of database so what
could be the debris that happens during
come during these flooding events so
most of the damage that happens is not
just because of the water but for
example this let's say assume there's a
car that is floating in and that blocks
the building now the water that has
flowed is not able to flow past the car
so kind of the water level builds up a
little bit around there and now that has
more loading onto the structures in a
way so we don't really have a let's say
a database that says this is the kind of
event that happens these are the kind of
debris that are coming in and so on so
forth so we are trying to build um let's
say use YouTube videos and post Hazard
videos to do object detection to map out
what are the kind of events and what are
the kind of debris that would come in
because of these events and how do we
use that in our physical simulation to
not just look at just the wave but also
to look at the debris so that would give
us a much more let's say more robust uh
let's say uh let's say evaluation of the
structural response in a way more in a
way so that's that's so there's a lot of
a consulted effort going to get this
into the hands of the city planners and
Structural Engineers and also uh
particularly with regard to also
insurance companies and so on but the
progress is I would say reasonably
slower than what we would like uh we
would of course like them to immediately
integrate into their design philosophies
but I think that takes more time I think
it's that we need a more concerted
effort there yeah yes thank you thank
you very much in this sense what you're
doing uh that uh it is interesting
example like Pro company scientists were
doing the old climate prediction model
right it used to be quite accurate
and uh nevertheless show company was
doing what they were doing yeah they
were doing the same stuff
and so you you you are making a product
which uh insurance company can make and
then I can rephrase my equation uh are
you considering to uh like bring this
information to actively what activities
not only to companies
yeah so they can affect government and
companies
yeah okay yeah yeah so yeah because
because of problem is extremely
multifaceted multi-disciplinary we are
also we try to reach out to the
geophysicists and uh let's say climate
scientists and people who are in the
let's say Geo geological area in a way
kind of let's I would say who are
looking at more like the uh things like
sedimentation erosion and all of these
things as well and the climate change
what sea level rise as well to see how
this can also be incorporated
incorporated into their workflow uh
biggest problem is some of these
simulation that we do are very local in
a way right so even though we can do a
large scale simulation
we are more focused on let's say our
building or like let's say tens of
buildings or for example a critical
infrastructure maybe a nuclear or a
chemical plant or something like that
which is around the coast so it's more
local than looking at the global
infrastructure itself uh so so there's
this still uh we're reaching out to them
but then I think they are looking at the
different scales
so there's still a bit of let's say a
mismatch in uh discussion so so one of
the biggest thing that we are trying to
do is firstly to reach out to uh let's
say academics and faculty even in the
humanities area because they look at the
post-disaster event how how do
communities let's say
um how is the damage changing after
after this damage happened how do
communities what do you say uh come back
to normalcy I would say I'm I'm not
getting that word but then let's say
that they have a disaster they're all
displaced now they can't have to come
back to their homes and how much time
does it take for these things in a way
so even the this is this would be our
very first step to see if we can make
the change there so that uh this this
amount of time that people need in order
to come back to their homes can be
reduced in a way so if you can let's say
take a community and predict the kind of
damage that could happen depending on
the events can you improve the
resilience of the community can you make
it better so that uh they are less
affected over time because of these
events and so on uh but then yes this is
a effort to reach out to climate side
tests and those who are modeling sea
level change but I think uh there we
need to start communicating in the same
language I think that both the
communities need to start talking in the
same language I think that's where
there's a bit of a mismatch at the
moment all right that sounds good okay
um if if it's okay if you have a uh more
questions thank you thank you thank you
very much
I guess
um you can ask RJ um you know send an
email and then the other will be happy
to answer you yeah yeah
there's a another question by Jeremy and
he has the you mentioned the building a
digital twin for adding aiding in making
decisions is your twin comprised of the
surrogate or the full auto model that is
um is the intent of the twin to be used
in real time is the twin and the
decision making with the twin aware of
the uncertainty you are quantifying
yeah those are the questions oh yeah
yeah so so the idea of
digital twin is essentially comprised of
both the surrogate model and also based
on the actual full full Fidelity
simulations uh we essentially uh I
forgot where I put that yeah but then we
essentially don't want to just uh limit
it to the surrogate model but then we
also want to have full Fidelity on a
structural side we don't have much of a
problem with running a full Fidelity
because most of these structural models
are made of wheels and plates and
structural Elements which run reasonably
fast for example you can run hierarchy
like each simulation probably takes a
few seconds maybe at most a very complex
building simulation might take a little
longer uh but we can run a full Fidelity
simulation we don't necessarily need a
surrogate model but having a surrogate
model allows us to span a whole bunch of
space and makes it much easier to look
at it in a way so they you can run
either both a surrogate model or a full
Fidelity model
you know
okay sounds good okay next question is
by Alan uh oh well no it was not a
question it was this he was thanking you
what a great job okay is there any other
questions from audience
no okay well then let's thank uh um our
speaker I say today for the wonderful
talk and if you have a
um well you know the additional question
then please email us at the
um directly I I think he will be happy
to answer you and also if if there is
any collaboration opportunity
um yeah please reach out to ADI um yeah
so yeah you're looking for collaboration
right definitely definitely you saw I
would be very happy if anybody has any
questions or would be interested in
collaborating uh then there's a lot of
opportunities in this area there's a lot
of open problems and I would be very
very interested uh you can also look uh
the my lab website is ijlab.com.uk and
you can also find my email there or also
I think this email is maybe there on the
invite and I would be very happy to work
with you as well and if you're
interested yeah wonderful wonderful
thank you so much well thank you thank
you so much
okay thank you so thank you so much bye